I know if you saw the first two episodes
of this show but it should be canceled
in instead all things comedy gave us
more of a budget so we rented this van
and now we're driving to Joshua Tree
this is Johnny Pemberton and that's
Barry Rothbart what
[Music]
oh wow Joshua trees I thought they only
grew out here but they don't they grow
other places do you know that the Joshua
tree is the only tree that's a sexual
what it doesn't need other trees to grow
that sounds like it's true it is true so
it just doesn't doesn't are
you sure they're technically trees
though are they what I don't know if
they're technically a man so what do you
want to get out of the trip Johnny
what's your goal for coming up here I
want to show you things of me that I've
never shown no that sounds nice very
what do you want out of this trip
Instagram followers well this vans gonna
help man it's gonna be great
John did Johnny did you ever think about
going by JP I've said about everything
yeah you autograph everything that's the
quote of the day I feel you name it I
guess ever thought about starting a
forest fire yes ever thought about
shooting this is much altered yes have
you thought about taking LSD yesterday
yeah cool man well we're here baby oh my
god you don't have to dig a hole the
oh this is cool this is nice
alright let's camp dudes alright let's
check out what this van does like I we
haven't with it yet here we go we
got a champagne Heineken I guess for
later
this thing sleeps for alleged this thing
pops up it pops up yep that's so
cool
whoa alright hold on whoa and then
this guy flips down dope now you can
sleep up here wow this is really cool I
do feel like oh Jesus
wow it doesn't get much better than this
you guys ever had a threesome in a tent
no not yet in a VW bus so weak please
get the out of here you ruined this
was so loud I was having a genuinely
nice time God when you got to go you got
to go no you like grunted this episode I
really going down on the wrong of
friends so there's my fifth and sixth
best friends but we got the coolest
dumbest van so I guess it evens out
weird where's everyone sleeping tonight
I honestly I'm terrified every time I'm
sleeping outside
but the Baron will be Lester most of the
night for me is I need to pay so bad but
I'm too scared to oh you know how bad
you have to pee to get out of a tent so
fat because you're on the ground and
then you have to be like I got to get
all the way like off of a bed you can
just hop off a bit yeah you got to get
all the way up off the ground you know
open the tent it's so cold
yeah try shooting twice I forgot that um
what's your disease I won't be shooting
twice what's your what it was your
stomach does the lightest kaleidos oh
colitis okay here we go the most
important thing before you start setting
up is to open up a novelty Christmas
Heineken mm-hmm because it will taste
different than normal you have to get
those bottles that sports teams use when
they celebrate it yeah we just one get
in here oh my god okay so it's it's
court what do you think this is Johnny
what are you gonna guess just beer but
it's court it's to make it feel special
it's absolutely beer you can Cork beer
so you pay more for it dumbass this is
why you guys are episode 3 I've said
this before Johnny turns into an uncle
there you go good right
I reminds me my time is in France
whatever you're like I'm just having one
day just one for me I got a bad cold
sore too just a heads up yeah that just
means you have herpes I got mine from
kissing you first night
yeah you want to go for a hike before
the Sun Goes Down let's do it let's go
I wanna see where we gotta go there's a
solid MIT have some fun Eve it's good
right it's a good bit
[Music]
oh boy travels in such must I guess is
to hike with a bag of beers one time I
was in Yosemite and I saw a piece of
like newspaper like on the ground and I
picked it up and somebody had thrown up
into it that's awesome and but people
saw me with the newspaper and I couldn't
just throw there was no garbage said put
it good I put someone else's
throw up in my car and then found the
garbage to throw it away
it was so bad to vomit okay to vomit
Johnny Pemberton knows like three trees
maybe he'll talk about him anytime he
runs into them Juniper right here it's
part of the fir family I believe doesn't
look like a mammal to me know when trees
and bushes have berries is that their
sperm no that's their seed seed but
that's their sperm right all right how
long how long before you eat someone
who's dead who died and it wasn't your
fault and you're hungry how long have we
been out in the in the woods let's say
let's say a week no food they're dead
immediately meanwhile they're warm
that's good why would you wait yeah I
guess to me could you wait for it to rot
what's the guy's name Atlas who holds up
the world it's so hard do you not I
mean the guy who holds the world like
this that's so much harder than like
just do like this that's he's the one
who does it so maybe he knows I'll check
it out it a jackrabbit where is this so
like that cougar you saw it's exactly
the cougar yeah yeah that's it that's a
baby Jackrabbit it's ears aren't big
enough it's so freaking area don't scare
it I'm not I'm just saying it's a
freaking cute I'm not scaring it as I'm
scaring it I'm not gonna scare it I'm
just gonna walk in here so cute that is
anything really cute want to climb up
here do it there's a quarry I'll race
you there I feel like I never know the
next move when I'm climbing I just saw
is just like I'll see what other people
are doing here's how I know it's not
that dangerous I just did it with a beer
in my
oh this is bad this is a mistake Oh
oh my god here we go
here buddy how we get down off you
figured out you can get up you can get
down okay that's like a jay-z song oh my
god it's great up here you can chill up
here
should we probably get down before
tonight we got plenty of time man the
sun's gonna be dope as
we're up here feeling the moment boys my
god yeah this isn't gonna be fun getting
down at all no it's gonna be totally
chill there's other ways down I like
that feeling of being unsafe yeah that
you can really like dread going back
down no man I'm finding us a different
route go have fun
there's no way that is a different round
so you make it past this year okay all
right the key is to make sure you put
enough weight on your feet so you
don't slip oh my god you did that
okay it's like a challenge pour beer on
the area the only way you're able to
stay on is with friction it's on me it's
all over you know it's all over me
oh oh
see watch us do this you have shoes that
work I like how you guys were like now
it's just walking we're just gonna walk
this is the part though I don't think I
can grip it okay daddy's getting worst
now I'm stuck it what's the next move
here
oh oh yeah oh oh that was not fun
good job yeah I did a good job levels
Brooks it's just that I'm so top-heavy
you know you can't beat this top-heavy
and do that I bureau all over my ass
laces craft beer huh
Wow that was all for the camera by the
way I could get that real easy
Drex it's weird that we're not even
hearing from him right I'm okay
are you having a moment holy
was by far the scariest okay thing
that's happened on this show what a
up what did you do did you fall I
got a trip I got in a pretty dicey
situation what is going on there mugger
up there no it's just like what are you
talking about are you injured no I'm
fine but like it was it got it got not
cool if you're not injured no I'm
totally fine let's try to be cool and
come down a different way wasn't cute or
fun I was it wasn't on camera
no it wasn't on camera that's the rumor
that's the real tragedy this whole thing
it was like terrifying all that happened
was I put my beer in my backpack because
I was like I'm not going out with a beer
in my hand what happened over here
actually I actually would bet a lot of
money that you go out with a beer in
your head I would played almost all my
money on that oh I see your wager
and double it sir yeah yeah all right no
harm no foul we're back all right let's
go let's go check out some trees Hey
one two three death averted death of a
bird hit one two three
come on man one jeez a death averted a
burden not saying it you don't have to
I didn't just part of the show is it
let's try it one time yeah I've heard it
yes you this is great though
like it's so fun who we should climb up
on that rock that rock it's fun I want
to climb up that rock with two beers in
my hand hmm I had that moment of like
this isn't funny yeah at that moment
every time someone says an introducing
Barry Rothbart I don't think you want to
die right after you were like I don't
want to die doing this
sure Brooks those are not climbing shoes
are also bear at the bottom yeah yeah
I've been running on these for a while
this is beautiful
this is beautiful it's
crazy right now this is
beautiful yeah now this isn't happening
I always get stuck I'm just the worst of
it the front of piss office not for
nothing but I like I see I have fun we
boys journey I are gonna see if we can
start a fire with flint and steel hey
Clara she in that little pocket so it's
like a little nest of things oh that's
looking great guys actually the most fun
thing I've ever done now put it down on
it to be honest I get down on it I think
this is gonna work
holy let me try I didn't have hope
until we almost got it
here goes oh blew it out blow on it
oh my god oh my god oh my god we just
not gonna be far with that oh hell
yeah
I'm like so stoked hold on hold on what
it takes is a really newspaper good
friends um a knife you bought from
Walmart an hour ago that you didn't know
how to Flint didn't know how to Flint
starter and then Johnny Pemberton's
hardcore love of making Kinlan oh my god
we did it dude no fun yes looking fire
when fire success I'm like proud of us
that's incredible
breathing here did you ever think you
would do a Flint fire huh no I don't
understand why that's such a big deal
you know it's easy for you to say Barry
over there not doing anything to help
making food sustenance you're gonna cook
on that we should wait you're gonna cook
on a fire you Fu and fire fu we got
beret Rothbart on the and the ones and
twos he's making kebabs tonight
I love him my chef coughs what's up what
do you think the ribeye came from like
what do you think the cows are from
puppy mills this actually looks great
isn't be great this should be cold it's
gonna be great
kebabs right here kebabs thanks mom
success whoo looks good you guys laughed
when I was like let's make steak this is
like this is weird how good this is
it's the marinade this cowboy right
here Barry
Johnny Jesus Christ so good
[Music]
initially air you're not smoking weed
right now quit you're the one guy in
this glue that smokes weed yeah I did I
did a lot yeah but you're smoking weed
and you're saying he's the one guy I'm
saying I normally don't smoke weed
berries the weed smoke you know you
don't think that like now around a fire
with friends is the time to smoke weed
again yeah absolutely not
you know think your pressure is gonna do
it for you know what's it gonna take for
you to smoke weed again I don't need to
get high on weed I get high on being
with my buds you suck so bad
all right I'm so ashamed
all right let's do this most scared
you've ever been in your life like it
from day my dad died not be high scared
me I mean like in a fun scary way that's
not scared most scared I've ever been uh
read this book real scary stories to
tell in art remember that yeah of course
with the looked like a demon threw up on
the cover it was like a pen ink
illustration that was really scary yeah
it was much scarier my blood was blood
but at 11 p.m. every night in this
mansion a dog ghost dog would run
through this mansion
this is a story I'm telling you what I
was scared of my whole life
you're killing usually is something you
read in a story tell another I'll tell
you but then I'd sit on Halloween night
1976 usually finish my story
visit I was reading HP Lovecraft I was
soon
meeting scary story nobody know scared I
was scared of the time 11 p.m.
whoa that was that's when a dog would
run through and we had an instead of
like my parents like knowing that that's
like what's the most heroic thing you've
ever done save the galaxy from the evil
empire I'm just a sadist thing that's
ever happened to you Schindler's List
all right the grandma died on me in
Hebrew school kid but I was waiting for
kids outside where I was waiting with
the grandmas because that's where the
kids wait after school wait so the
grandmas and the kids waited to say
that's where the grandmas wait for the
kids and I got out early and I was
hanging around by the grandma's and then
I feel this weight on my back and I was
off me and this woman hit the ground
like oh like that of laundry and
chanting coins like it was like it was
like heavier than laundry but like a
lady died on top she out of my back and
I got out of the way and she hit the
ground and and I was like what the
and I just walked away and walked home
and then I came back to Hebrew school
the next week and it was my friend this
guy Aaron died knew his grandma and I
was like era what happened your grandma
and he's like she doc what you think
somebody didn't came back somebody it
was terrifying a woman died on you yeah
bury your shoe melting you know wake up
in the morning to make some breakfast
when someone's shoes on fire
stop well alright night I see you in the
morning come on tonight
[Music]
I mean Johnny legitimately slept outside
with no tip I'd be afraid like a
rattlesnake would curl up why would they
do that
cuz you're warm yeah it's so cool they
don't want to move they want to be next
to a little warm body a warm boy I slept
below Barry it's not a lot of insulation
between this much plywood it was pretty
terrible but we made some coffee in
there this morning new coffee I slept
out here
I turned the propane on when I woke up
why just you know I'll see what would
happen for Barry oh and nothing happened
so you just leave propane on all you
want I guess Johnny what would you say
the van smelled like when you got there
this morning the van smelled terrible
this morning
it smells like um if a dog in its own
and then shut out the at 8:00
and then ate it again that's what it
smelled like okay getting a kiss from
that dog you both have dogs what's your
policies on dogs looking in your mouth I
don't love it hundred bucks policy is
you got to do it three times a day
yeah or you don't get fed you gotta have
that you look like an eccentric
billionaire yeah so you're gonna want to
let this cook for five to seven minutes
now let's let's move ahead I have a
finished version I can't start my day
without Breitbart are you guys the same
way
how many here's the real question how
many times do you think and I'm so
embarrassed like how many times a day do
you find yourself just I'm just like on
Breitbart like you're just like I was
just here and I'm bad
you know annulation how many times
you've been on Breitbart and then open a
new tab for Breitbart again I know you
mean it's like okay right Bart I go to I
just get on the internet and I type in
Breitbart calm it's like muscle memory I
don't type in bright bar about Conchas
when I open my computer it loads Safari
and the first page that auto loads is
bright bar.com okay sometimes I'm on
LegalZoom worried about you know my
divorce papers and then all of a sudden
I get on Breitbart and I'm like what's
up with Seth rich so top thirty favorite
parts of the trip hmm from 30 down okay
when Brooks almost died Hey
Oh your voice made the weirdest crackle
it did get a little that was so weird
like Mario and Mario 64 where he like
you know makes the triple Joe
1 2 3 success success dude
it's kind of squirrels are gonna be
going bananas on that yeah that's not
cool they'll be going egg wild nice he's
nice driving up here I had a really nice
trip I like being outside it's fun it
was good being outside nature huh Barry
Rothbart slept on top of me last night
literally and that's weird to say I
explored the the depths of my own
persona and the personas of my friends
Josh left on the ground like weirdo but
I admire it Johnny were you cold not at
all you were never cold at one point I
was cold a little bit yeah
so then that's not not at all well I
mean that's normal yeah I see it huh
great time at a nice time hearing about
how Barry and Johnny are happily married
with dogs and I'm like well I got can't
be show on YouTube so that was cool too
made me feel good about myself well I
guess it's off to the wilderness for me
so I think we wrap it up and get out of
here
you
[Applause]